[Música]
cuando me preguntan a qué me dedico y de
qué trabajo eso contestó bueno yo que la
gente sea más creativa que las empresas
que las organizaciones sean más
innovadoras me miran raro no me creen
muchos piensan este no labura
ya viene la pregunta y que estudie y
ajuste y ahí adonde digo bueno no sé soy
doctora en ciencias económicas bueno ahí
directamente se dan vuelta y se empiezan
a matar de la risa en realidad esto todo
es verdad hay hace 35 años que me dedico
a esto de la creatividad y la innovación
hacer que la gente sea más creativa que
las empresas y que las organizaciones de
todo tipo sean más innovadoras y empezó
casualmente yo estaba estudiando
administración en la facultad y recién
se empezaba a hablar en la década del 80
del siglo pasado del milenio pasado a
mediados de 1980 y recién se empezó a
hablar del pensamiento de lateral de la
creatividad de cómo eran esas soluciones
que no eran repetitivas ni eran
excéntrica si estaban ahí eran nuevas
pero además eran útiles más sutiles de
lo que siempre se hacía y empecé a leer
los pocos libros que había dos o tres
libros de una clase de 15 minutos como
ayudante de cátedra y los chicos del
centro estudiantes me dicen este tema
parece que está bueno no te animas a dar
un curso de seis clases dos horas cada
uno
de 7 a 9 de la noche digo mira no me
animo dando unos meses cuatro o cinco
meses y preparo las seis clases bueno
dale dale preparada estoy preparando las
clases y le dije bueno mira solo te pido
una cosa no me metas más de treinta
personas porque no no no nos recién no
ya no no lo voy a poder manejar se me
imaginaba seis grupos de cinco personas
cinco grupos de seis personas intereses
olvidarte más de 30 no se va a notar con
suerte se va a notar 15 a 20 personas es
fantástico llega septiembre que es
cuando voy a dar el curso y veo que hay
algún líder la facultad dentro a
vuestros castiga te cambiamos de aula
listo voy y me acerco y voy el auditorio
dicen puestos castiga mira nos dijeron
que el máximo de personas eran
trescientas pero se anotaron 350 y lo
mismo no
y yo me encontraba ahí
y yo me encontraba ahí con 350 personas
que iban a venir durante seis clases dos
horas cada día que nos tenía que manejar
bueno cuando uno no es muy ducho lo que
hace tira mucho material rápidamente
entonces que hice en esa clase de dos
horas dije todo lo que tenía preparado
para las seis clases
el tema es que terminó la clase
buenísimo a la gente le encantó y llegó
el jueves que viene
no había internet no había google no
había computadoras desde ese entonces no
sabía qué hacer bueno empecé a preparar
que hice empecé a comunicarme con gente
de diferentes lugares con un músico con
un artista con un psicólogo iba
preparando cada clase dejé de trabajar
pedí licencia
dejé la facultad por por un tiempo y me
preparaba todos los jueves a la tarde
terminada esa clase para dar la próxima
mantuve la gente la gente sigo viniendo
ser no como una especie de bola de nieve
desde la gente que quería venir y cuando
terminaron las clases dije me tengo que
dedicar a esto porque está está
buenísimo lo que me di cuenta en
realidad que lo que yo estaba haciendo
no era enseñando creatividad sino
estimulando a la gente a que sea más
innovadora que piense diferente y que
hacer eso estaba buenísimo y que me
gustaba y que sirve entonces pensé por
qué no hacer una prueba acá con ustedes
se animan a hacer un ejercicio de
creatividad
bueno vamos a hacer lo siguiente yo le
voy a pedir a todos que saquen algo para
escribir que puede ser el teléfono en
notas o algún papel y lápiz para que
escribe y le voy a pedir por favor que
escriban que anoten en eso se esté en
donde quieran tres favoritos tres
favoritos pero que ustedes quieran de lo
que ustedes quieren pueden ser un hobby
película mascota música deporte artista
postre favorito personaje serie marca
auto cómic lo que quieran tres favoritos
de lo que ustedes quieran por ejemplo si
yo tuviera que poner los míos pondría
luis alberto spinetta que me gusta la
música de spinetta qué sé yo que sé
cuánto después pondría la película
historias de new york' el tercero
episodios sean específicos no me pongan
asados familia fútbol monago
is pondré yo el bar importó fi que es un
bar que no es el cairo pero por qué se
han sido buenos aires- un bar que a mí
me gusta ir le voy a dar un minutito
para que todos tengan sus tres favoritos
saben que cuando los tengan levanten la
mano ponemos un poquito de música hasta
que todos tengan los tres favoritos
hagan
[Música]
ah
creo que muchos ya lo tienen vamos a lo
siguiente ahora a ver atención
es interesante lo que va a pasar
cuando yo diga ya va a empezar a sonar
una música y le voy a pedir a cada uno
de ustedes que se pare y comparta sus
tres favoritos con la mayor cantidad
posible de gente en todo este auditorio
a ver de uno en uno no vale agarrar a
cinco y mostrarle que no ya de uno en
uno tiene que ser y cuando le muestro
mis tres favoritos a la otra persona
tengo que escuchar lo que nos vale decir
esto sólo estoy una mi parte y me voy no
hay que explicar entonces cuando yo digo
ya suena una música y van a mostrarle
sus tres favoritos a todas las personas
que puedan de uno en uno
preparados listos arriba adelante
[Música]
ah
voy a moverse quedar congelados en el
lugar que están y se sientan al lado de
la última persona con la que
compartieron se sientan de a dos si no
tienen con quién levantan la mano y
buscan se sientan de a dos se sientan de
a dos
ahí está había dos aunque no se conozcan
por supuesto van a hacer lo siguiente
van a hacer lo siguiente lo primero que
van a hacer es van a chequear si lo que
tienen no es muy parecido
si yo se vea yo elegí comer entran ya
cocida y el otro puso elegí riñoncitos
al bueno acá alguno cambia entonces el
rey no citó pasa dormir si estás
maratónicas no cambian ósea eligen uno
cada uno elige uno y simplemente
chequean que ese que eligieron que ese
que eligieron no sea muy parecido al
arte del cambio de un súbdito
y ahora que cada uno tiene un favorito
la persona tiene un favorito la persona
ve tiene otro favorito con esos dos
favoritos inspirándose en ellos
inspirándose en cualquier cosa que tiene
que ver con ello no hace falta que sean
totalmente literales inspirándose en los
dos en ambos van a crear un producto o
una iniciativa social o un servicio o
una aplicación que de algún modo
contenga a los dos contenga los dos se
entendió y le van a poner le van a poner
un nombre
pongan un nombre marketinera no me
pongan un nombre formal porque yo me
llamo jorge y él marcela
un nombre una descripción corta y una
frase síntesis un eslogan ganador nombre
y descripción corta y frase síntesis no
es fácil por eso le voy a dar bastante
tiempo tienen cuatro minutos adelante
[Música]
de trípoli está privado
se dice
muy bien vamos a ver cómo sale esto
tenemos dos personas en el auditorio
tenemos a noche y tenemos a sophie que
tienen micrófonos levanten la mano si
hay algún dúo que se anima a contarlos a
todos que lo que hizo pero mientras les
del micrófono les voy a explicar cómo se
cuenta primero no expliquen cómo se les
ocurrió bueno ella eligiera mar del
plata yo elegí comer fe no nos cuenten
de dónde salió porque si no la gente en
vez de pensar si está bueno o malo va a
pensar si lo hicieron bien o si lo
hicieron mal ustedes directamente con
toda la fuerza este es el nombre está la
descripción este es el eslogan y si nos
gustó lo aplaudimos estamos vamos con
quien con sophie adelante te paras
nombre mi nombre es el link y mi
compañera adriana eso y nosotras yo mi
preferido era el helado y en tuya la
película ave fénix es inevitable y
nosotras pensamos y creamos la heladería
ave fénix así como el helado tiene un
proceso de transformación
también lo tiene así que ese es nuestro
nuestro nombre y es una heladería donde
donde vas a comer a renovarse y arreglar
mente renacer salir renovada de ahí
salir como cuando tenés el aplauso
dale nacha
parece parece los que hablan les
presentamos a fernanda y liliana vamos a
presentarles a blue para que sus hijos
desayunan es una máquina para hacer
licuados y como no hay frutas azules y
algas nes les encantan la fruta el color
azul esta máquina crea los smoothies
azules fuerte aplauso blue jugos azules
burgueses fuerte abrazo próximo próximo
próximo precio del galés
nosotros somos mayrán y bruno y nosotros
creamos el producto terminator 3.0
terminator 3.0 que es una cámara de
realidad virtual para ver el día del
juicio final en base a la película
fuerte aplauso pervierte
dale dale uno más
bueno facundo marcos nuestro está
patentado la app conectado se llama
conectado conectado conectado go
entonces yo quiero pasear a mi perro y
para no ir solo con leonardo conectado
tengo la demanda de quien está también
para villar parque urquiza hablando y
venimos acá
[Aplausos]
bueno me encantaría escucharlo a todos
pero no vamos a poder hablar porque
porque este es un típico ejercicio
creativo un tipo de ejercicio de de
innovación porque sale bien porque 4000
personas que no se conocen en tres
minutos hacen algo y las cosas que salen
nos divierten aplaudimos nos parecen que
sí son interesantes porque se dan
determinadas cosas que son las que uno
busca cuando uno busca creatividad
primero hay una palabra podría haber
usado la palabra más conocida pero me
gusta esta porque es una palabra creada
por un autor que se llama arturo kessler
que es disociación disociación es cuando
mezclas dos cosas que antes no estaban
combinadas cuando combinas cosas que
antes no estaban combinadas cuando
combinas dos planos que antes no estaban
combinados el primer elemento de la
creatividad tiene que ver con esta
innovación también tiene que ver con
poder juntar cosas que antes otro no
combinó o que antes no estaban
combinadas o que antes en el lugar donde
nosotros estamos nadie había combinado
es lo primero que se entrega cuando se
entrena de creatividad la mitad de las
técnicas de creatividad la mitad de las
técnicas
tienen que ver con esto por ejemplo la
técnica analogía tenemos que resolver el
problema en una fábrica en vez de pensar
en una fábrica pensamos en el sistema
digestivo de determinado ser vivo
tomamos elementos para ver cómo fluye el
alimento ahí y tomamos ideas para
adaptarlas a la fabrik para ver qué pasa
con el tema de las líneas de montaje por
ejemplo otras técnicas tienen que ver
con juntar aleatoriamente cosas y ver
qué es lo que pasa por ejemplo alguien
debe haber visto la película que lleva a
polo 13 en un momento hay un problema en
la nave entonces que dice bueno
traigamos todo lo que tienen arriba de
la tener todo lo que hay arriba arriba
de
en el espacio en donde están y
combinamos eso a ver qué se puede hacer
eso es lo primero que se busca cuando se
busca creatividad buscar en otros lados
combinar cosas hay autores incluso que
dicen que la creatividad tiene que ver
cuando combinamos disciplinas diferentes
cuando vemos la física con la mirada de
la música cuando vemos la matemática con
la mirada de la de la física cuando
vemos la de cualquier tipo cuando vemos
el tango con la mirada de otro tipo de
disciplina por ahí empezamos a crear
primer punto acá se juntaron cosas
diferentes por eso primero les hice
corregir eso de que a ver que era muy
parecida porque si no no les iban a
salir cosas buenas segundo punto fluidez
la fluidez tiene que ver con que hayan
muchas ideas tiene que ver con que uno
pueda crear como si esto fuera un juego
libremente aceptando todo fíjense que
para que haya fluidez hay un montón de
técnicas una es el torbellino de ideas y
muchísimas técnicas más yo acá hice
algunas trampitas para que haya fluidez
una de esas trampitas es darles total
libertad pero a la vez darle una meta
muy clara
si ustedes se fijan la meterá super
estricta tienen que estar en cuatro
minutos tomar dos cosas que no conocen
mezclarlas ponerle nombre poner la
descripción ponerle eslogan
terriblemente exigente pero con
autonomía total cada uno podía hacer lo
que quiera es uno de los elementos de la
fluidez y hay muchísimos más metas
claras autonomía capacidad para escuchar
todo tipo de ideas las dos cosas primero
que buscábamos en los ejercicios cuando
hacíamos cuestiones de creatividad
tenían que ver con estos dos elementos
conectar cosas diferentes y tener clima
de fluidez aproximadamente cuando empezó
el siglo 21 todas estas cosas se
empezaron a ser mucho más fáciles hoy
uno tiene la posibilidad de conectar
cosas diferentes compartiendo
información en tiempo real información
que viene de cualquier lado viendo
vídeos viendo imágenes viendo
absolutamente todo por eso los
ejercicios de creatividad que tienen que
ver con resolver cosas muy puntuales
cómo hacemos para formar el número 6 con
4 fósforos ese tipo de cosas no tiene
mucho sentido porque uno lo golea y
listo tiene mucho más sentido otras
cosas si entramos en 2
nuevos elementos de la creatividad el
primero tiene que ver con la motivación
acá ustedes pueden encontrar una pista
de esto porque sale bien esto porque es
interesante hacerlo entre otras cosas
porque parten de cosas que a uno le
gustan porque parten de sus favoritos la
creatividad tiene que surgir de cosas
que a uno le interesan lo que nosotros
llamamos motivación intrínseca no porque
me obligan sino también por el mero
placer de hacer esta tarea la motivación
lleva a la creatividad cuando se dice
las crisis son las únicas no eso no es
tan así la crisis detona ideas
ingeniosas de corto plazo la motivación
la pasión en lo que uno hace es lo que
garantiza creatividad a largo plazo por
qué porque cuando uno está motivado un
adquiere lo que llama solvencia también
pensé en si poner esta palabra o no una
palabra muy vinculada a lo económico
pero a mí me encanta porque tiene que
ver con solución solvencia es saber
resolver estar preparado para resolver
cosas
tener herramientas tener soluciones a
mano motivación y solvencia es como una
especie de loop de circuito que se
retroalimenta mientras más nos gusta lo
que hacemos más ganas nos da de ser
solvente mientras más solvente somos más
ganas tenemos de seguir profundizando y
estos cuatro elementos son claves para
todo lo que tenga que ver creatividad
pero no sirven si no se le agregan otros
dos elementos que son los últimos que
les quería contar que tienen que ver
primero con el proyecto que no tiene que
ver con qué haces sino para qué lo haces
que hay detrás de lo que haces cuál es
tu proyecto de vida cuál es tu proyecto
de carrera que quieres transformar
cuál es tu propósito hoy no importa
tanto las ideas porque las ideas están
en google importan para que las querés
qué hay detrás de esta idea que vos
tenés y el último punto tiene que ver
con la co-creación con crear junto a
otros junto a otro que está en tu equipo
pero también cuando vos tenés tu público
y le mejoras la vida a tu público de
alguna manera es una cooperación porque
tú público con él
está creando con vos de esto se trata
hoy la creatividad y la innovación de
estos tres pares de palabras disociación
y fluidez motivación y solvencia y
proyecto y cooperación los dejo con una
definición que tiene que ver con esto
que es mi definición propia y favorita
de lo que es creatividad y lo que es
innovación la diferencia de creatividad
innovación es que la innovación además
de tener que ver con producir cosas
nuevas y valiosas esas cosas producen
transformaciones la gente las adopta y
con eso transforma y un montón de
inventos que no son innovaciones porque
están buenísimos pero la gente no los
transformó en algo para su vida y no
transformaron nada cuando se transforma
haya innovación mi definición
creatividad es sostener los proyectos
que nos apasionan especialmente en época
de crisis no traten de tener ideas
estrafalarias porque hay crisis traten
de sostener los proyectos que nos
apasionan cuando hay momentos difíciles
la mejor creatividad es cuando uno dice
puede pasar lo que sea pero yo voy a
insistir en lo que me apasiona con ideas
valiosas originales
horas no solo originales la originalidad
sola no es creatividad para que haya
creativa tiene que ver originalidad
novedad pero también tiene que haber
valor sentido cambiarle mejorarle la
vida a alguien y si vas a ser innovador
transformar tu contexto para los demás y
junto a los demás la creatividad no es
solamente hacer cosas para nosotros sino
que es hacer cosas para nosotros y junto
a los otros muchas gracias
[Música]